Speaker 1: I am going to show you an unreal video
of a sweaty Donald Trump losing it in
a free speech, speech, crushing video
we've said before, where's the policy? The
Republicans have abandoned policy. Well,
in this video posted to truth, social troth,
essential and Rumble Truth Central. Yeah,
Donald Trump is announcing what sounds like policy
if indeed he were to again become president of the
United States. And it is chilling. Look at this.
Speaker 2:
If we don't have free speech, then we just don't
have a free country. It's as simple as that. If
this most fundamental right is allowed to perish,
then the rest of our rights and liberties will
topple just like dominoes. One by one, they'll go
down. That's why today I'm announcing my plan to
shatter the left wing censorship regime and
to reclaim the right to free speech for all
Americans. And reclaim is a very important word
in this case, because they've taken it away.
Recent weeks, bombshell reports have confirmed
that a sinister group of deep state bureaucrats,
Silicon Valley tyrants, left wing activists and
depraved corporate news media have been conspiring
to manipulate and silence the American people.
Speaker 1: Understand that that is not an accurate
representation of the Twitter files. We have done
numerous deep dives now into the Twitter files.
No crimes were committed. Twitter's own terms
of service were not violated, and Trump's White
House had the same access to individuals
at Twitter than did the Biden campaign.
Speaker 2: They have collaborated to suppress
vital information on everything from elections
to public health to censorship. Cartel must be
dismantled and destroyed, and it must happen
immediately. And here is my plan. Here we
go first. Within hours of my inauguration,
I will sign an executive order banning
any federal department or agency from
colluding with any organization, business
or person to censor, limit, categorize or
impede the lawful speech of American citizens.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, what's funny about
that is it was the Biden campaign who would ask
Twitter to remove pictures of Hunter Biden nude.
Trump is talking about government actors. His
administration was the one empowered to do that in
the time described by the Twitter files. Trump is
really talking about himself here. It's stunning.
Speaker 2: I will then ban federal money
from being used to label domestic speech
as mis or disinformation, and I will begin
the process of identifying and firing every
federal bureaucrat who has engaged in domestic
censorship directly or indirectly, whether they
are the Department of Homeland Security.
Speaker 1: By the way, I don't know if you
notice that, but this is clearly based on how much
Trump is sweating and slurring the type of video
he needed 100 takes to get completed.
Speaker 2: The Department of Health,
Human Services, the FBI, the DOJ,
no matter who they are. Second,
I will order the Department of Justice.
Speaker 1: These cuts are just unbelievable.
Speaker 2: To investigate all parties
involved in the new online censorship regime,
which is absolutely destructive and terrible,
and to aggressively prosecute any and all
crimes identified. These include possible
violations of federal civil rights law,
campaign finance laws, federal election law.
Speaker 1: Now, I just again, to try to inject
some reality here. As an example, they have
these the MAGA people have been trying to make
the case that when Twitter acted on removing nude
images of Hunter Biden, which are illegal in most
states and violate Twitter's terms of service,
that that helped the Biden campaign. Therefore,
they argue it has monetary value. It was
not disclosed as being of monetary value,
as a campaign contribution. Thus it was a
crime. No serious legal expert is buying
even a crumb of that insane hypothesis.
Speaker 2: Securities law and antitrust
laws. The Hatch Act and a host of other potential
criminal, civil, regulatory and constitutional
offenses. To assist in these efforts. Emerging
House Republicans to immediately send preservation
letters. And we have to do this right now to
the Biden administration, the Biden campaign
and every Silicon Valley tech giant ordering them
not to destroy evidence of censorship. Upon my
inauguration as president, I will ask Congress to
send a bill to my desk revising section 230. Yeah,
to get big online platforms out of censorship
business. From now on, digital platforms should
only qualify for immunity protection under section
230 if they meet high standards of neutrality.
Transparency, fairness and nondiscrimination.
Speaker 1: This is bonkers. I mean, this is
just unreal. It's Trump not understanding
anything, claiming he's going to do things
he can't do and won't do and hopefully
will not even get the opportunity to do.
Speaker 2: We should require these platforms
to increase their efforts to take down unlawful
content, such as child exploitation and promoting
terrorism while dramatically curtailing their
power to arbitrarily restrict lawful speech.
Fourth, we need to break up the entire toxic
censorship industry that has arisen under the
false guise of tackling so-called to miss this.
Speaker 1: The sad thing about this is
that this is such meaningless drivel
that his followers think is just God's gift to
statements by candidates and disinformation.
Speaker 2: The federal government
should immediately stop funding all
nonprofits and academic programs.
Speaker 1: All right. You get the
picture. This is extremely free speech
crushing. He wants to tell social media
platforms what they have to publish. It's not
sounding very much small government, is it? If
Trump were to get another term, I assure you he
would try to do these things. He would probably
fail. But it's better not to even give him that
opportunity. Absolutely. Deranged stuff. Unreal.